The answer is both the second and the third are true. We have our restaurant
class, which has, its base class is object, and object has many methods
including both init, and str. Restaurant doesn't define any attributes but it
inherits all of the attributes defined by object. What's happening somewhere
inside print is this object is being converted to a string by calling its str
method. The self object for str, is this restaurant object. So the self object
is a restaurant which means its a restaurant instance so that's why the second
one is true, its also an object instance. Every object that we create is an
intance of its own class as well as all of the super classes or the base classes
of that object. So that's why the third one is true also. So there's nothing
magical or mysterious going on, other than Python implementing a simple object
system that does this.